-Joel, since
you are a great actor
and you're quick on your feet,
I thought that it would be fun
if we put your movie knowledge
to the test.
It is time for "A to Z."
Here we go.
-♪ A to Z, A to Z ♪
-Now, here's how it'll work.
You and I are going to
have a conversation
about our favorite movies,
but the catch
is that each time one of us
brings up a new one,
the title has to start with
the next letter of the alphabet.
We'll go back and forth
and see if we can get
all the way from A to Z.
Are you ready for this?
-It's the English alphabet,
right?
-[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
Well, tonight, we're using
the English alphabet.
That's correct.
I'll start off the conversation,
and then you'll start with the
letter "A" and your first movie.
Joel, this summer,
blockbusters, giant movies
coming out this summer.
People are getting back
into the theaters.
What are you excited to see
or what do you remember
your first blockbuster
that you saw?
-Oh, I'm very excited
to see "Almost Famous II."
-[ Ding ]
-Oh, yeah.
Yeah, that's a great --
I loved the first one, yeah.
-Yeah, the manager in that
was incredible.
-Yeah. He really was amazing.
Deserves an award.
Thank you very much.
I'm looking forward to the
reboot of "Bad News Bears"
just to see if I can --
-[ Ding ]
I mean, because I'm a big fan
of the old ones.
-I get that. Do you ever --
Jimmy, I know that, like,
New York gets hot in the summer.
Do you ever
just want to get away
to, like, a "Cold Comfort Farm."
-[ Ding ]
-Wow!
[ Laughs ]
-You ever seen "Diner"
with Mickey Rourke?
[ Ding ]
-Yeah, I've seen it. It's great.
Tim Daly is in that, as well.
Boy, that answer just went
"Every Which Way But Loose."
[ Ding ]
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, I almost belong
on a "Funny Farm."
[ Ding ]
-Boy, wouldn't that be
a "Great Muppet Caper."
[ Ding ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I remember "Great Muppet
Caper." I used to watch --
It was a double feature.
That and
"Harry and the Hendersons"
in the same thing. It was good.
[ Ding ]
-Hmm. Yeah.
And the thing about Harry is
that he was, you know, real.
It wasn't a puppet.
Everyone knows
that Sasquatch is real,
but a lot of people, when
I get into that conversation,
we just have
"Irreconcilable Differences."
[ Ding ]
-Yeah, but do you ever see
the documentary about
the real dinosaurs.
[ Laughter ]
The theme park with, like,
real dinosaurs in it.
It was a documentary.
-Oh, yeah. "Jimmy Neutron"?
-No.
[ Cheers and applause ]
No. "Jurassic Park"
is what it was called.
It's a great documentary.
-You know, I don't know that,
and it's just nice
to be with you, Jimmy,
'cause you're a real
"King of Comedy."
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you very much,
because I thought what we had
was "Lost in Translation,"
buddy.
-Ohh.
I didn't think because
I don't think it's lost at all.
I just know
that "M is for Murder"!
[ Ding ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I want to tell you something,
and this is just between us.
I've "Never Been Kissed."
[ Ding ]
-Oh. You should go to "Orlando."
-Are you sure?
[ Laughter ]
You sure?
-I swear you should go
to "Orlando," you "Oldboy."
[ Laughter ]
-Okay. Yep.
-Okay.
Well, whatever. I hope
you find some "Office Space."
-[ Ding ]
-Yeah, there you go!
Thank you. I will because -- -
-Those are all movies.
I swear!
-No, I know they are.
Yeah, they are. You know
what I always think is funny?
I don't know if to say,
"Pirates of the Cuh-ribby-in"
or "Pirates of the Cara-bee-in."
Isn't that weird?
-Uh, I think
it's "Cara-bee-ahny."
It's a very --
It's an unknown pronunciation.
But, anyway.
[ Sighs ] This one's hard.
-Yeah.
-Okay, if I say the phrase,
"We are the mods,
we are the mods,
we are, we are,
we are the mods,"
do you know what
I am talking about?
-Yes, yes, yes.
You're talking about the band --
Pete Townsend and Roger Daltrey.
-"Quadrophenia" is the movie!
-That's correct.
"Quadrophenia" is a good movie.
[ Ding ]
Yes. It was almost as good
as "Road House."
[ Ding ]
-It was no "$cheme" that has
the dollar sign for the "S"
that you appeared in,
Jimmy Fallon.
[ Ding ]
You remember that.
[ The Roots laughing ]
-You know, I don't remember that
because that was not what
the movie was called
when I filmed the movie.
-Was it "Sheem" or was it --
-I was in a film.
My first film was called --
Yeah, "The $cheme" is what
they ended up calling it.
That's very interesting.
It was --
-It was really good,
if you can find it.
[ Laughter ]
[ Audience oohs ]
-It came out
and sank like the "Titanic."
It really did.
-Aww. Well, they should've used
"U-571" to go get it.
[ Ding ]
-Oh, uh, maybe they'll use
"Valkyrie" in the movie.
[ Ding ]
Tom Cruise
is in a lot of movies.
-He is.
-In the backlot of Universal,
they have a big --
a big thing that
you can drive through.
-Right. That's right.
I've been there on that tour.
"The Wicker Man" tour.
-[ Ding ]
-That's not true.
-I was thinking
"War of the Worlds,"
but, yes, "Wicker Man" tour
was the one, yes.
-Oh.
-But it's like all space stuff.
Some of it you would see in
the movie "The X-Files," maybe.
[ Ding ]
-You mean "Fight the Future"?
"X-Files: Fight the Future"?
-That's correct.
Is that what it's called?
-I don't know.
The Spanish translation
is "Y Tu Mama Tambien."
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
We're not done!
-Well, you left your mark
like "The Mark of Zorro."
Joel McHale!
"Crime Scene Kitchen."
"Crime Scene Kitchen" premieres
May 26th at 9:00 p.m.
You're so fun.